i mentioned to my son that i was having
uh this man back on our show he's been
here in person
pre-pandemic back in the day and back on
nbc is my one of my son's favorite shows
zoe's extraordinary playlist
airing tuesdays at eight eastern and its
streams on peacock which is the
exclusive home of the show's
emmy-winning first season
as well from zoe's extraordinary
playlist skyler aston back on the show
how you been brother
hey rich i've been pretty good i've been
pretty good it's good to be back on the
show
it's good to have you back here it's
good to have you back here my uh
your show your new show's on in our
household all the time my son is binging
it the first season
he can't wait for it to come back he's
so excited to watch it uh this week
oh i'm so happy to hear that yeah season
two is off to a pretty good start we
just premiered on tuesday
and uh it got a really warm reception
well it's a beauty it's a warm show man
it's a beautiful show with some
incredible music
uh how is it described to you when uh it
was bounced off you
right off the bat well for those who
don't know about the show it's a show
about
a girl named zoe clark who gets this
basically superpower where she could
hear people's thoughts through song
which on paper sounds like
it could go either way as far as corny
or not but kind of how it's interwoven
within her story her work life her
romantic life her family life and even
sometimes through like some pretty
traumatic situations
it's actually a really interesting
coping mechanism and
we've found that like audiences not only
appreciate the humor and the heart but
also the pathos of the show and
uh i've done a bunch of musicals before
and it seems like within that genre
we're trying something fairly new and um
and and your your cast members are uh
supremely talented uh as well there's
you know one after another after another
where everybody
is just uh spectacular at it uh
do you have like some sort of you know
like uh
not not a fantasy football sort of like
a fantasy karaoke or something like that
in a show like this
skyler you got like yeah i mean
i i'm such a weirdo i for some reason
like would love
dave matthews or like fish to be on the
show
as like some like chorus and a me doing
some sort of a bar
song of theirs right we haven't had like
too many like
uh musician cameos because generally we
have like
you know people on the show like oscar
winner mary steenburgen peter gallagher
from the oc
alex newell from one of broadway legends
the lead of our show jane levy
so we always have some really great
people coming in and out but
anytime i get asked like who's my
fantasy person it always like
ends up being a music artist for some
reason
not like lin manuel would having him
come on our show
would be great don't you think i mean
well would be great
that would be quite something what's
your what's your go-to uh karaoke song
scala cause we were talking karaoke just
last hour
what's your go-to yeah you know i feel
like
uh it's always kind of uh forgot about
dre
or like spice girls randomly i like to
do stuff that i could kind of pawn off
as humor
because since i do sing professionally
it'd be very odd if i just got up there
and straight up went to town like in a
very earnest way i think that would kind
of rub people the wrong way so i always
try to like get in on a big group song
or do something that's a little out of
my own comfort zone that's too humble
that's too humble i mean you should i
think so i will say at the zoe's uh
playlist like first uh premiere party
we closed down the bar and i had just
enough to drink and people were egging
me on so i did do i like closed it down
with new york state of mind so i
definitely had my moment
legitimately go for it i mean is that
your billy joel go-to
is that you know that's my big billy
joel go-to my girlfriend loves when i
sing that song oh well that's yeah um
i i billy joel's a huge inspiration for
me well and of course
we've actually sang pressure on this on
the show before too
that which is by the way talk about
pressure to be able to do something like
that knowing that billy joel's out there
potentially even watching this sort of
thing
um yeah i mean you know cause again i'm
i'm more of a lower timber guy
uh schuyler so i do sinatra um
but but the billy joel normally i can't
i can't
carry that uh but vienna is right in my
that's in my
wheelhouse vienna is is my billy joel
wheelhouse
scholar vienna is a beautiful song i
feel like yes staying with the old
crooners the dean martens and the frank
sinatra's
if you really want to broaden you if you
want to like split the difference there
you go in my way because there's a
couple like high notes in there that
you'd have to
kind of grin down and bear it for well
everybody's looking at me right now
because i i just recounted
last hour uh skyler that um when i sing
my way
at the very end you know at the very end
the crescendo the big moment
i take the microphone and you know it i
i usually do have a few in me as well
i take the microphone and as i finish i
take the microphone and i
literally i slam it down on the floor
and walk out of whatever room i'm in
i out i would i would love to be in that
room
but but then i as you know then it comes
and it finishes with one last
much more uh i guess softer
final line i come back in and finish it
that's
you know because i have to have to put
on a show you know what i mean i have to
i have to put on some form of a show
staging is equally important in karaoke
or any performance skyler aston here on
the rich eisen show which of the green
bay packers is most talented
and pitch perfect too if you got to go
for one which one
i got to say david bacciari
boy yeah he came in hot like he came in
excited
i mean the way he drinks a beer you
think that's impressive
[Music]
in person too but like now that was
amazing and
uh i guess i gotta go with clay matthews
too because he really brought it there
was this big like thing where they kind
of
rip off his sleeves and he he flexes
into the camera and i mean that guy's
done so many commercials and stuff so
his screen presence was pretty
pretty polished but let's stick with
bhaktiari here why would you choose him
if you had to
again um go with a teammate here for
uh a a singing moment why would you go
with bhaktiari
where are you going i think bhaktiyari
he came kind of like prepared
i think not only was he like a really
big fan of the
uh of the first movie um like
legitimately some of those guys were
really big fans and they like used to
learn all the choreography and do it in
the locker room
some of them were just like there
because you know it's exciting uh
david i could tell like super wanted to
be there but also was like asking a lot
of questions about the filmmaking
process
i was very interested in like how i got
my start and like we've we've remained
good friends i'll like text him on game
days
and so i think like that kind of like
passion for something new yes really
pushed him over the edge for me so which
is your team
skyler i forget since the last time you
were on here we we've we've talked
about as like as if i we are both
uh jets fans unfortunately that's right
now it all comes back to me okay
yeah scholarly tough fears
well this is uh
this is what i've been talking about all
year long and i saw it come in week one
i even wondered if we get the first
overall pick do we just tell sam darnold
farewell and
via condios um i was you know
normally i do appreciate the competition
and respect the prideful nature of
national football league players but i
was hoping they would just tank the
whole rest of the damn season
just for trevor lawrence yep that's how
i felt
uh i i i've been i i like i've been
dealing with this not to jump sports uh
you know i've been dealing with this
because my teams are
met nicks and jets so it's kind of tough
and
finally it looks like the knicks are
starting to turn it around and it's
very exciting i am about a year
and a half away from feeling that with
the jets potentially like some sort of
new beginning maybe a young squad some
draft picks
but i don't know if you're aware because
you might be doing press for much of the
day scott
are you here aware that the mets uh just
traded for francisco lindor
of the cleveland indians and then
decided to
bring on carlos carrasco's salary too
because um what's the phrase that i used
earlier
chris brockman uh for the owner of the
met stephen cohen he's so rich he uh he
defecates nichols defecates nichols
that's uh that's the phrase that i used
earlier on this show
skylar did you hear that news i don't
know the mets
i love the mets and i've i actually have
not heard about that trade
it's like a lot of off-season moves that
they make i'm always
i'll believe it when i see a kind of guy
especially when they go after like
vets who i don't know how they're going
to be on the met sometimes that you know
where their curse um so i've been burned
so many times that
the the mets i take very lightly like uh
so
so my dad is the opposite he gets his
hopes up for
he was he had his hopes up for the jets
you better watch out they got some
receivers no no
i mean no donald's got an arm but once
he's healthy and it's like oh my god
and then you know in four weeks after
they lose four he goes same old jets
so i'm like i'm cautiously optimistic as
far as like
you know these moves go with the map by
the way what you did
uh on the show we have since since your
last appearance we have
come up with a new segment on the show
where you need to
uh give your sports takes if you kind of
need to
force yourself to believe it like it
sounds like what your dad did you go
higher register
like hey you know hey like donald's got
an arm and he's got some receivers and
it sounds like your dad went higher
register on the 2020 new york jets
earlier this year he went high register
and then in four weeks he goes deep into
the base
i don't know what to do this is
ridiculous oh my gosh
you know what i mean it's just a
depression i can't deal with the
the bipolar nature of being fans of my
team so i i kind of like zen out until
until they start to start to show
promise and now here i am hook line and
sinker for the knicks
it took me like you know eight games to
be like this is a squad
by the way i think for tomorrow's higher
register segment i think scholar action
just gave me an idea
i might i might go next tomorrow for the
higher education oh my gosh
i know i mean look at that julius randle
and tom thibodeau and they've won five
of their first date i mean like that
something like that i think i'm
workshopping it right now with you right
and like hey like quickly these young
guys you know they're not afraid to
compete i i don't know i like it they
got shooters
they got shoes you see you just you know
he took
that's it it's unfortunately you got to
go higher register for every last damn
one of your teams
unfortunately but the mets no longer
seriously this guy is
he you know apparently the rumor is
although the creators of billions and
brian koppelman and david levine say
it's not true
that the owner of the mets a lot of
people believe that the uh the
axe or the bobby axelrod damian lewis
character was based on the new owner of
the mets they say it's not true but it's
two there's too many
pieces of connective tissue right there
scholar
yeah i believe it might not believe it
well look man hey look
uh congrats on on this uh wonderful show
i will be
watching my my son is in the middle of
his first week returning to
uh remote learning so we've got uh the
season premiere already loaded up
uh on peacock for him to watch and then
we'll be out there every tuesday night
so thanks for the call appreciate it
that sounds awesome thanks for talking
rich i appreciate it
say hi to your son yes xander says hello
he wanted me to say hello to you
schuyler so there you have it
perfect perfect hi xander thank you for
watching fantastic you got it thanks for
the call skyler
you be well that's skyler aston at
skylar aston with an
a on both twitter and instagram
right here on the rich eisen show hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that
watch more right here